I'd like to introduce the second speaker
mm
the children lecture series I should
begin by expressing our gratitude this
speaker series of is founded by pranking
program the sciences and Humanities
which was made possible by the generous
generosity of Richard and Barbara
Frankie the series is named after Robert
trollman Stirling professor emeritus of
chemistry molecular biophysics and
biochemistry and senior research
scientist and diagnostic radiology and
it is named in recognition of his role
as a founding fellow of the Whitney and
as an unwavering supporter of the
integration of science McManus
I also added this lecture series of held
in conjunction with the seminar habits
of mind clock by Mia on problem
I'm sciences and Tamar Gendler
philosopher Dean of Faculty of Arts and
Sciences who is humanities and together
we represented the marriage of these
great disciplines there's a lot of
pressure for us I'm I'm delighted today
to introduce susan goldin-meadow she is
the Beardsley Rummel Distinguished
Service professor to the Department of
Psychology at the University of Chicago
I'm gonna go on to say some nice things
about her but first I want to qualify
this by pointing out that I'm through
discussion last night she is not
currently the most famous member of her
family that's a science graduate and she
is now a third-year student and medical
school at University of Otago and she
has become famous for many reasons but
one is a series of YouTube videos that
she has made dedicated to explaining
that the experiences of medical students
including one call I don't know which is
the tune of frozen's
little dose which is approaching two
million hits
I may start singing my talk she's
purchased the president the continent
Development society he is the founding
editor of the journal language learning
and development she is a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences as
well as an elected fellow of America of
the American Association for advancement
of science she has won the awards for
her mentorship for her teaching and most
recently she won the William James award
this was like that this year for
lifetime achievement embraced the basic
research from the association of the for
psychological science I just want to
before vote just read one of the words
in the dedication of the word for her us
Susan Golda meadows research examines
deep enduring important issues about the
nature of human thought and language her
massive influence in the field stems
both from her trailblazing research and
from her lucid exposition of the
implications of her research to human
cognition so p.m. she graduated to an
undergraduate at Smith College where she
spent a year in Geneva at the edge
heading an institute and what she
actually worked with the great
developmental psychologist John Vianney
who wrote her reference letter for an
out inhale the letter O in oh that's
just one day well she she did there talk
to her work at UPenn and and part of the
work there was developed in addition to
this incredible research program looked
at at deaf children who were raised by
hearing yes so they had no primary
linguist
they have used and exploring what for
collaborators the jetter language of
these children and is this amazing
research program because it provides us
with an unusual inroad question of how
much of language is the product of what
sort of natures and how much of its
acquired through this environment and
this is a beautiful case study exploring
the sort of particularly looking at
grammar and morphology how much seems to
be stemming from the child him or
herself um so she's continued this work
but she also does a series of studies on
gesture and speakers like us and she has
made many discoveries about this
including discovery summarized in her
book hearing gesture um before before
Susan came on to the scene many people
could be excused for believing that
gesture was just had but there's no an
extraordinary body of research showing
that gesture both reflects law including
thought that he wouldn't have expected
to find and construct slide and and I
won't go into detail that this research
program because gonna hear but they'll
just just say that that that that it
hits the perfect sweet spot of all
academics aspire to and that it's
theoretically extraordinarily rich it's
a practical relevance and it's just
really cool
thank you so much well it's gonna be a
little tough to live up to that
introduction but I'll do my best it is
such a pleasure to be at Yale part
because I just have this soft spot in my
heart because my daughter went to Yale
and loved it so you're getting a good
education so I want to talk today about
a habit of mind or at least a habit of
speech that's really very robust and
that is the fact that whenever we talk
we gesture we move our hands across all
cultures all ages whatever and I want to
begin by just giving you an example an
illustration of what I'm talking about
here this is a man who was asked to
reason about a moral dilemma and his
speech is the little airy-fairy it's a
little esoteric but what he does is he
moves his hands and he sort of grounds
his ideas he talks about two different
ideas that come into competition and
when they do that that's the moment of
negotiation okay
so just watch him in listen to
this is the point where people develop
negotiation even in play that side so we
can clearly gesture when we're talking
about something very abstract but we
also gesture when we're talking about
more mundane things like giving
instructions in fact directions to get
from one place to another it's really
impossible to give directions without
gesturing and just watch this person who
was asked to get from one place to
another so we go right and we cross the
driveway which is
okay so there's really nothing unusual
about her gestures but there is
something unusual about her that many of
you probably already noticed and that is
that she's blind
she's congenitally blind she has never
ever seen anybody gesture doesn't matter
the fact when she talks she gestures
despite the fact that she has no model
for that and what that suggests is just
that this moving our hands is a really
robust phenomenon and will come about
even if you've never had any model for
doing so so the question I want to
address today is whether Paul indicated
gestures more than hand waving and of
course I want to argue that it is much
more than handwriting or it would be a
very short talk and I want to first try
to convince you and to do it relatively
quickly that gesture reflects knowledge
and to give you this sort of first
studies that convinced us that people
aren't just moving their hands they
really are conveying substantive ideas
and often those ideas are not expressed
in their words that's where it gets sort
of interesting but I want to suggest
actually the gesture goes beyond
reflecting thought and that it can
change our knowledge not just reflect it
but change our knowledge and it can
change our knowledge in two ways that
I'll go into they can change our
knowledge through is the fact that it's
part of communication and it can change
our knowledge through cognition and I'll
make this clearer as I go along and then
finally the last part of my talk I want
to just take tackle what makes gesture
of mechanism of change why does it work
we really at some level have no idea but
I'm gonna give you the hypotheses that
we're currently entertaining and we can
talk about it okay so just to reflex
knowledge how do we know so I want to
begin with a Piaget Ian's task it was
picked up in my youth here when I was in
piaces lab what Piaget does is he gives
children or did gives children two rows
of checkers make sure that the child
thinks that there's the same number of
checkers in both rows and then he
spreads went out and he asks them if
it's the still the same number of
checkers non-conservative number of
checkers and what I'm interested in is
not the fact that they're not
conservative but how they justify that
sponsz okay and in particular whether
they justify use the same justification
when they gesture as when they speak so
here's a kid who's a non-conservative
them out and she says that in her hands
as well as her mouth same information
more or less
so this is a kid who's produced what
we've been calling a gesture speech
match because she's talking about
spreading and she's gesturing about
spreading and she's to be contrasted
with this one equally convinced it's
different different number of checkers
he actually focuses also on the movement
and he says they're different because
you moved them but watch his hands what
he does is this he starts to pair up the
checkers in one row with the checkers in
another row which isn't how anybody
moved anything it's really about the
one-to-one correspondence between the
two rows of checkers okay
so that's pretty smart actually he's
saying that it's different but he's
indicating with his hands and just his
hands that he's getting a glimmer of
insight into one-to-one correspondence
and into conservation so that all right
maybe these kids differ in their
cognitive understanding of this task and
at an underlying level let's give them
all instruction and just see who profits
from the instruction and what you see in
this next book this actually yes this
kid produce what I've been calling a
mismatch because he's talking about
moving and he's gesturing about
one-to-one correspondence okay and
here's the data this is the proportion
of children who improved on the
post-test okay the children who were
mismatches prior to instruction are in
blue the children who are matches prior
to instruction are white you're more
likely to profit from instruction to
learn you're ready er to learn if you're
producing a mismatch on this task then
if you produce a match on this task okay
so is this true only a five to eight
years old eight year olds dealing with
conservation we're going to look at
another task so we picked this task
three plus four plus five equals blank
plus five pretty easy for you guys but
for fourth and fifth graders
particularly in America it's hard and
when it's hard when children get it
wrong they do two things either they add
up the numbers on the left side of the
equal sign then they put that in the
blank or they just give up and they add
up all the numbers in the problem and
they put that in the blank okay but as
we all know I hope you had supposed to
add up the three and the four and get
seven and that's the correct answer okay
so here's a kid who has added up all the
numbers on the left side of the problem
and she says that both in her speech and
in her gesture she points at the 5 and
the 4 and the 3
she points at the eye of the 5 and the 4
and the 3
she's produced to match in the sense
that she's talking about adding up the
number to the equal sign in both speech
and gesture contrast her with this one
who says exactly the same thing but
watch her hands she points at the 5 5 4
& 3 so she points at the other 5 2 so
she's doing a doll in her gestures see
it yeah okay so she is produced a
mismatch in the sense she's talking
about adding up to the new equal sign
but gesturing about adding up all the
numbers so he did exactly the same thing
took these kids none of whom knew how to
solve the problem gave them all
instruction look to see who sort of
caught on to the instruction those are
the old data from conservation I just
showed you there's the math data kids
who are mismatches prior to instruction
are more ready to learn more likely to
profit from that struction and kids were
mattress okay this is an experimental
situation we engineered the instruction
we sort of had control over this does
this happen in the wild well we brought
real teachers in to teach real kids to
see what would happen
teachers did their whatever they wanted
and then after it was all over we gave
the kids a pretest and a post-test after
was all over we divided the children
into three groups kids who never
produced mismatches throughout the
entire task kids who started to produce
mismatches as they were interacting with
the teacher and kids who produced
mismatches from the very beginning okay
and what you see here is the number of
problems that were correct on the
post-test they were zero at the pretest
if they never produce mismatches they
didn't produce we get very far if they
produce them in the middle they sort of
did pretty well and they did best if
they had started by producing mismatches
so even in the real world even in a real
teaching situation we find that that
mismatch predicts learning okay so what
this suggests here is that gestures
conveying substantive information it's
not just gesturing or not they're all
waving their hands everybody's gesturing
turns out it's really hard to talk about
conservation without and math without
gesturing so they're all gesture it's
the nature of the gestures particularly
in relation to the words that they're
producing
that's really important here the other
thing that's important is that the
thoughts that they're expressing in
gesture aren't always the same thoughts
as they express in speech so it's giving
us another window onto the thoughts that
they under they're thinking about these
problems
okay so reflects thought but does it
change it our thought
does it change our minds so I want to
now walk through this and first consider
the way gesture can change your mind
through communication and then through
cognition so the idea here is kids
gesture and I've already shown you
there's a lot of really rich information
in those gestures that somebody who's
talking to them could take advantage of
them but do that teachers could pay
attention to these gestures and adjust
their instruction accordingly and if
they do that one might hope that kids
would learn so that's the hypothesis
that I want to entertain and the reason
we thought this might be true is because
of anecdotes of the following swing kids
sees that problem and he starts giving a
pretty incoherent instruction
description he's just talks and talks
and talks and at the same time he's
holding up his fingers under the fours
he points simultaneously at the left
floor and the right four and at some
point the teacher goes oh yeah well you
can solve the problem by adding the 5
and the 3 and putting the some in the
blank kid never mentions the forest in a
speech the teacher never mentioned the
fours in her speech it's like the white
elephant in the room but it's really
important for the strategy that she gave
and from this moment on the kids solve
the problem correctly so it looks like
it was a teachable moment that the
teacher recognized only from looking at
the kids hands now find we have one
example of this does it happen routinely
does it happen ever again so I'm now
going to look and see whether teachers
actually pay attention to the gestures
that their children that their students
produce and do they adjust their
instruction accordingly so to do that
I'm going to go back to the study that
it just told you about where we brought
in real teachers to teach real kids ok
and what we looked at was their
responses to children who mismatched
throughout mismatch in the middle or
never mismatched and what we found first
is that they actually do change their
instruction just they didn't know these
these category
these categories are all post hoc but
they changed their instruction and in
fact what they do is they give more
different kinds of correct strategies
when they're talking to mismatches the
blue in the red dental mattress you know
this is sort of good if you teach you a
math problem and you're giving one
strategy maybe that's better to actually
give two strategies because if the kid
can't get one it could get another so
multiple strategies might be a really
good training regime for teaching this
problem and the mismatches are getting
this good instruction here's something
they do that's a little more less
intuitive here they produce more of
their own mismatches and talking to
mismatching kids to both in the middle
or at the end mismatches or throughout
mismatches now the misfit they're not
actually copying the kids because the
teachers don't happily produce incorrect
responses and they don't produce
incorrect gestures that's good but they
they produce two correct responses one
in speech and a different one in gesture
all it will illustrate that in a minute
but it's interesting that they we find
more mismatches to the mismatches then
to the kids and then to the mattress and
as I showed you before miss mattress
learn of course but we don't really know
why from this study because the
mismatching kids could be learning
because they're just ready to learn or
the mismatching kids could be learning
because the teachers are giving them
just the right input so in order to
figure that out in order to really
figure out whether the kids learn we've
got to do an experiment where we
manipulate the input so that's what we
do next
we actually manipulate the gestures
learners see and we think it out we used
what the teachers did spontaneously as a
guide to setting up our little teaching
regimes so we have three groups kids who
got no gesture kids who got matching
gesture and kids who got mismatching
gestures okay and you got one or the
other we also gave the kids first just
one strategy in speech so they would get
this equalizer strategy I will
illustrate it in a minute and then
either get it with Justin's speech in
speech and gesture or they get equalizer
in speech and a second strategy that we
call add subtract in gesture and again a
little straight in a minute but notice
of course these this instruction has
more information in it it's actually got
two strategies in it
so in order to control for that we had
another group who got two strategies and
speech exactly the same information EQ
and a s but within the same modality as
opposed to different modalities and then
to you know finish out the design we
prettied it up when we we had groups of
each sort okay so now let me show you
what it's all about what this really
means so this is melissa singer who was
the instructor and this it was her
dissertation she's talking about
equalizer in speech and she divs no
gesture okay so that's equalizer here
she does again she says exactly the same
thing she's very very good at saying
exactly the same thing and she gives a
gesture this time it's the equalizer
gesture which we picked up from teachers
when they talk about equalizer and from
kids when they know what they're talking
about
so it's an equalizer treating the two
sides each side in the same way
okay and here's the last one says
exactly the same thing again but she in
her gestures she points at the 7 the 8
and the 5 and she does this little
takeaway gesture under the other five
you can do this salvus problem by adding
up the numbers on the left side and
taking away the number on the right that
works perfectly well so it's a we call
it an add subtract strategy
the same amount the 15th us also
okay so and then we had about 20 kids in
each group we had six groups so let me
show you what happened first let's look
at just the number of strategies and
speech when strategy and speech versus
two strategies in speech we thought two
strategies in speech was going to be a
good thing that's what the educators
tell you all the time it was a disaster
in this problem it just blew the kids
out of the water it was just too much
information I think and they just didn't
profit from it now what I'm gonna do is
split up each of these bars into the
gestural components matching mismatching
and no gesture and what we see one
strategy in speech better than two
strategies and speech but there's a
really interesting pattern here and what
I said before isn't totally accurate two
strategies is terrible when they're both
in speech but two strategies is just
fine if one's in gesture and one's in
speech because that's that this big red
bar is it's a mismatch these mismatching
responses one strategy in speech and one
strategy and gesture and that turned out
to be the most effective instruction
this was actually a surprise we did not
expect that's something we have
different information it's complimentary
it's information that can be integrated
but it truly is different and that's
really effective instruction okay so
I've been arguing that gestures terrific
for learning it's really good but it's
not quite the argument I want to make
what I really want to make argue is that
gestures powerful it can be used for
good as in the examples that I just
illustrated or it can be used for evil
as in the example that I'm about to show
you the kid at the problem assemble a
six plus five it goes blank plus five
the child puts 18 in the blank and the
teacher says ah you added up these three
numbers to get your answer and she
points at the seven the sixth the five
and then the other five she actually is
doing an ad all strategy she then goes
on and gives a pretty incoherent
explanation I've done men and while
she's doing that the kid puts 23 in
blank if you add up all those numbers
you get 23 let me show you this example
18 so she'd write rights in eighteen
okay seven six five and then the other
five so she pointed it all four numbers
and now she's a little incoherent
and then I don't blame him for paying
attention to his gestures actually she's
so shocked I mean she should have no
clue it was to where that 23 came from
but maybe it didn't come from her hands
but maybe it did so this is the place
where gesture is really leading the kids
astray and we all know when you use our
hands we don't always pay attention to
what we're doing okay before I leave the
math desk I want to just this isn't just
about math I think gesture is powerful
in lots of domains so this is an area
that we all know about it's eye witness
testimony so we all know that we can
mislead people by asking targeted
questions if you say what color was a
hat he was wearing you're very likely to
get hat responses whether or not he was
wearing a hat but hat responses will
come to you what you're supposed to do
we should say what else was he wearing
okay that's the right way to ask the
question so what we did is this is Sarah
brothers whose work this is brought a
musician into the classroom and we
videotape that we knew exactly what
happened and then we interviewed the
children over a series of weeks to find
out what they thought happened okay so
here's one of these interviews and all
you really need to know is that the
musician was not wearing that okay here
we go
well I think many of you noticed already
when Sarah asked the question she said
she has a beautifully open-ended
question but she polluted it with a
little gesture a hot gesture and it
turned out we got as many hot responses
- what else was he wearing as we got to
what color was the Hat he was wearing I
think this is really important research
actually because this is this really
applies to our legal situation where
none of this stuff is written down
verbal transcripts I would make it - to
the proceedings not gesture and it is
the case that an interviewer unwittingly
absolutely unwittingly can influence how
a witness is taking in information it
also works the other way around so let
me show you this next example this is an
instance where Sarah was interviewing a
little kid who said nothing but watch
so imagine that in a transcript here it
sounds like the interviewer influenced
the kid and brought in the glasses when
in fact it wasn't true the information
really dammit then therefore it would
have been eliminated you would say oh no
no no you contaminated the kid but in
fact the kid introduced the glasses and
the interviewer just picked up on it so
I actually think it for moments when new
information is being introduced into a
trial or into a testimony it's important
to check who did the introducing and
whether it might have been introduced in
gesture by the other person
don't okay so gesture can influence us
through communication how about through
cognition so my hypothesis before was
that kids gesture teachers pay attention
kids change their minds this hypothesis
is pretty simple
kids gesture and adults gesture I don't
think it's just about kids kids change
their minds just by virtue of the fact
that you're gesturing it's not just
reflecting your mind it's changing your
mind that's a harder argument to
convince you out so let me see if I can
do it so I wanted to do this we have to
again manipulate the gesture that
learners do not what they see but what
they do so what we do is first we taught
one group of kids to say this I want to
make one side equal to the other side
this equalizer strategy which is sort of
the underlying principle for solving
this problem and they're told to say
these words before and after solving
each problem this group no gesture at
all
okay then we taught another group of
kids to say exactly the same thing but
they were told to move their hands in a
particular way they were told to do what
we call a grouping strategy to point put
a v3 and the two and then to point at
the blank because that's how you solve
the problem you group the numbers that
are unique and you point at the blank to
control for movement because those two
groups differ in movement whether
they're moving or not we have a third
group that we call the partially correct
group and what we did is we told them to
point at the wrong two numbers okay
now this should be a total disaster if
all that gesture does is direct your
attention to something
but if gesture is actually doing
something a little more it might not be
such a disaster because what this
gesture does is it tells you about
grouping adding these two things and it
tells you there are two sides of the
problem so we called it partially
correct to see whether how bad it would
be to have your eyes directed to the
wrong numbers of the problem okay and
this kid then
okay and then we gave them all
instructions just to give you some idea
I mean we were not light on instruction
we told them how to do it we don't
matter how about we didn't gesture we
didn't mention grouping but they got
everybody got all the same instruction
okay and the three groups or correct
gesture partially correct no gesture and
this is what happened so what we have
here is the mean number of problems
correct on the post-test they were all
zero on the pretest kids who had correct
gesture produced correct gesture we're
better than kids who produce partially
correct gesture than kids who got no
gesture this so this is really an
important result it isn't actually what
I predicted I did predict that they
would be a total disaster and we revised
our view that it's partially correct in
looking at what the kids did they
clearly were getting information out of
the gestures that they were producing
about what grouping is not just about
which numbers were important okay and we
got you know so idea here is that the
kids were extracting movement meaning
from their own gestures and the reason
we thought that was true is that nobody
produced grouping to start in speech but
after the whole thing was over the kids
who had been taught to do this started
to talk about grouping so here's an
example and I've listed here what the
kid is saying it's really hard to hear
this is a kid who all he did was do this
to begin with and he gets it this kid
really understands if he knows there's
equal Adamses but they've invented you
know he really really understands this
problem presumably all from having made
this grouping gesture because remember
that during the lesson the experimenter
never ever produced grouping in either
speech or gesture the kids only produced
it in gesture and so we think that
grouping really came from the kids own
gestures we're really changing their
minds by making them make these
movements which initially are rote they
have no idea what they're doing
and we can talk about that man if you
like okay so we've told kids how to move
their hands and that can make them
change their minds in something I have
we've done another series of studies
which I don't have time to talk about
which are really interesting from the
point of view of scaling up if I'm a
teacher and I have to figure out which
gestures I want to teach my kid for each
math problem it starts to get a little
overwhelming so what we did is we took
cute brought him in and we just said
next time you solve this problem
just move your hands gesture and they
gesture and it turns out they produced a
lot of mismatches and then we gave them
all instruction and the kids who he had
created sort of these man-made
mismatches turned out to be ready to
learn so just by telling the kids to
move their hands they started producing
all of these new ideas and gesture and
that made them ripe for learning that
could could really scale up because it
may just be really effective to say okay
explain this when you explain it just
move your hands when you're doing it and
by virtue of doing that that makes you
open to instruction that's pretty easy
you're always got your hands with you
okay so now let's talk a little bit
about what makes gesture a mechanism of
change as I said I don't really have an
answer but I got a bunch of hypotheses
that I want to tell you about okay so
the first idea is that gesture activates
an action information here okay and to
do this I want to go back to the Tower
of Hanoi which I suspect many of you
know it's a logical puzzle you're
supposed to take these disks which are
on one peg and move them to another peg
you can only move one disk at a time and
you can't put a big one on top of a
little one
this study that we're building off on
was done by cook and tenon house and the
they have it's really nice evidence that
gesture is growing out of action so what
they did was a gift gave people a tower
of Hanoi a real Tower and they had them
do the movements actually move the disks
and then talk about it or they had
another group of people who just
performed the Tower of Hanoi on a
computer and when you do it on a
computer you can slide the little disk
over it doesn't have to go over the peg
but if you're moving the disks your disk
has to go up and over right so that's
what they literally did then those
people were told to talk just say what
they did explain it to somebody else and
interestingly the people who saw who did
the task with the real objects made
their gestures go up and over higher
then the gestures of the people who did
the computer test now the gestures the
computer tests weren't straight because
there is sort of a sense of moving them
up and over but these are significantly
higher than those guys okay they also
had these they had somebody listen to
these people and the listeners were then
instructed to go off and do the tasks on
a computer and on the computer you could
just slide them over okay and so this is
what happened here's these are the
people who gestured these are the people
who saw those gestures and went and here
remember they could all be flat it could
be absolutely flat but the ones who saw
the gestures that went up and over were
more likely to move their little Mike
Mouse's license whatever their their
computer mouse up and over than the
other guys so these gestures right here
are growing out of action and those
actions are affecting a listener now
what I want to convince you of is that
those actions action gestures not only
affect the listener but they affect the
speaker that in producing a gesture I
can be changing my own mind okay so our
hypothesis here is that gesturing adds
action information to the gestures
mental representations and if that's
true people's thoughts about a task
a change in predictable ways when they
themselves gesture alright so what we
did is we went we use this Tower of
Hanoi task we had real disks big one was
really heavy you had to lift it with two
hands little one was pretty light you
could lift it with a single hand if you
wanted to okay
so they all had to do this task and then
what they had to do was explain it to
somebody else just explain what they had
done so he was in the and we encourage
gesturing but it turns out you sort of
can't talk about Tower of Hanoi without
gesturing it's really hard to so here
she is just watch her
okay so they did it once they explained
it then they did it again and when they
did it again we divided them into two
groups one group was a no switch group
they got exactly the same disks as they
had before and not surprisingly they got
better they fewer moves faster time
better another group was the switch
group we switched the disks they looked
the same but they were not the same the
big one was now the lightest and you
could lift it with one hand and the
little one was really heavy and you
couldn't lift it with more than one hand
okay and what were interested in looking
at it couldn't lift it with only one
hand what we're interested in looking at
is the relationship between the gestures
that they produce during that
explanation phase and how well they
performed that second time around when
they were particularly in the switch
group when they were surprised because
you can gesture about this little disk
using one hand or two hands if you just
about it with one hand you're sort of
setting yourself up for disaster because
a little bit later that disk won't be
able to be listed with one hand so here
you see if the person you saw actually
talked about that little this with one
hand I'll show you again okay but you
don't have to this guy chose to talk
about it with two hands okay and as it
turns out so this is the difference in
score between the second trial in the
first trial these are guys in the no
switch condition getting better is going
below the zero they did get better and
guys in the switch condition did not get
better but more importantly the guys in
this nose in the switch condition did
not get better more the more they
gestured with a single hand so the
proportion of one-handed gestures the
more they used a gesture like this the
worse they did subsequently which you
know it's it because again they're
setting themselves up for disaster by
gesturing in this way so this
correlation was true for the switch
group but it wasn't true for the no
switch group okay
so that suggests or at least to our I'd
like to argue that gesturing is changing
knowledge but it could be reflecting it
nonetheless I mean maybe I just you know
I think about it as light and so I
gesture about it with a single with one
hand okay so if gestures really changing
knowledge we should find
differences between switch and no switch
only when they gesture so we wanted to
get rid of gesture we actually wanted to
have them explain again and have no
gesturing but as I said we couldn't do
it because when you you have to gesture
when you explain otherwise this task or
it's really too hard so we just thought
rid of the explanation phase so they
solved it once we switch the disks in
one group and they solved it again okay
and what we're looking at is the same
kind of data so what is it the data here
that I showed you before this is what
happens when we get rid of explanations
nothing there are no differences it's
really interesting because we switch the
disks that's a massive change we switch
the disks but it doesn't matter if you
switch the disks unless you gesture
about it and unless your gestures are
this little single handed gesture okay
so the switch in jae-in waits was an
impediment only when the adults gestured
prior to it okay so gesturing adds
action information to our mental
representations if the action
information is compatible performance
goes along swimmingly if it's not
performance suffers as it happened here
in this instance now the thing to notice
also is that what this is a logical
problem wait is totally irrelevant
nobody ever talks about wait why would
you talk about weight in a test like
this it's irrelevant but if you're
gesturing you have to use one hand or
two pens which implicitly brings in
weight so they didn't get a choice
weight sort of came in by virtue of the
fact that they're gesturing and once it
was in it influence how they thought
about this task okay one of their last
thing I want to say they also move these
disks right they solved it first then
they explained it so what about the
moving did that make a difference so we
didn't want to look just at the original
move we did we did the task again we had
one group do it explain it and gesture
and do it again and another group did it
and just did it again
and then did it a final time with the
switch and we made sure that the
gesturing group and the acting group
the single the the object that little
disk with one hand an equal amount of
time either they literally moved it or
they gestured about it an equal amount
of time okay so we replicated our effect
in the gesture condition and in the
action condition nothing
this isn't a bad embodiment I mean or if
it is it's very much more subtle than
just using the body or not because the
bodies involved in both I think it's
when gesture represents it has to be
when the body is representing
information that it is most powerful in
changing our minds okay so to summarize
gesturing with one hand changes the
speaker's mental representations and
that makes solving the Tower of Hanoi
problem more difficult after the width
the the weights have been changed and
the other point to take home is the
gesturing can be more effective than
action in changing mental
representations so gesture activates
action information but gesture I would
like to argue as I've sort of just begun
to argue is a special kind of action
okay so gesture grows out of action oops
but at the same time it represents
information and just by virtue of the
fact that it has one leg in real action
and one leg in abstraction and
representation maybe it could be a
pretty useful tool for a kid a learner
not just a kid but any learner to go
from the concrete to the abstract so we
wanted to contrast then real action in
our math problem versus symbolic action
so we made up this little we made our
task into a concrete action task and we
put little plastic numbers on the board
and we had people pick up the numbers
and sort of instantiate a grouping
strategy with the numbers themselves
either real acting on it or gesturing
about it concretely or abstractly I'll
show you what I mean
so in this case the kids were doing the
grouping strategy they picked up the set
the 5 and the 7 held it and grouped it
and put it under the blank
okay concrete gesture did exactly the
same thing that just didn't move the jet
the numbers okay there just gestured
okay and then abstract gesture that's
the gesture you saw before so as in our
previous studies when we manipulate a
gesture they had to do it before and
after they solved each problem and then
when you add them a post-test and we
varied the number of types of problems
they got on the post-test so even they
got problems that were very similar to
the ones on which they were trained so
for example if you got five plus two
plus a B was blank plus eight on which
you were trained you got problems where
the blank was in exactly the same spot
you can solve those pretty easily by
just adding the first two ends you don't
even have to understand much just add
the first two M's but there's new
transfer problem so we're a little
different we move the blank around we
put it in a different spot so if you're
just mindlessly adding the first two
numbers you're gonna get it wrong you
have to figure out which two numbers to
do so this is a little bit harder and
far transfer we got rid of the equal
atoms entirely and you really need to
understand equivalents here you need to
understand that there's an equation in
order to solve this correctly okay so
let me first show you that what they did
on the trained problems this is the
proportion of kids who succeeded on all
the train problems and there were no
differences across the groups actually
there were pretty much the same action
concrete gesture and abstract gesture so
this action which a little weird
admittedly picking up numbers and moving
works pretty well to learn how to solve
problems of this type but now looking at
near transfer problems it turns out this
is where it gets interesting because
action drops off but gestures just fine
so something about and the movements are
identical right literally identical for
the concrete gesture the only difference
is that you're doing it in the air above
it more symbolically more
representationally
and that works really well to transfer
them to the near transfer problems but
the action doesn't and if we look we're
now a far transfer there's some evidence
even if the abstract is even better okay
so what this is suggesting is that
actually
can help kids learn the problems on
which they were taught it's really good
for a learn it's not it's a bad teaching
device which is good because there's a
lot of manipulatives that are used in
math classes I mean that's what momenta
Padilla's sorry there are little numbers
and rods that you put there it's not so
bad for learning that but it's not so
great for extending that learning to
something else that might be relevant
and transfer of knowledge is really what
we're about when we're trying to teach
people okay all right
last point gesture well actually two
words gestures in a different modality
from speech so when we gesture we use
our hands and we use our mouths okay and
maybe it's the fact that we have two
different modalities that's really
important here that it's really crucial
that just handed mouth are working
together but there's another possibility
and that possibility is that there's a
second representational format that
gesture offers because language our
speech is very categorical and discrete
okay it's how it gets language gesture
on the other hand is much more mimetic
and much more pictorial image istic it's
conveying information in a really
different way maybe that's what's
important and all you really need to do
is have a discreet representational
system along with a more mimetic one
cool okay you can't ask that and hearing
people because all we do is we produce
language of their mouth and gesture with
our hands but you can ask it about
signers because signer is gesture people
who use American Sign Language friends
sign language any sign language
they also gesture as Karen Emery showed
many years ago and it turns out their
gestures are also mimetic analog whereas
their signs are very categorical and
discrete so now we have the perfect
opportunity this is all in one modality
but there are two different
representational formats so we can ask
now whether signers produce a gesture
sign mismatch and what does that look
like and if they do produce a gesture
sign mismatch do those mismatches
predict readiness to learn are they like
hearing people and if
it's all about hand and mouth it
shouldn't work right because for the
signers it's not about hand and mouth
but if it's about two different
representational formats it should work
great okay that's what we're going
alright so here is a deaf kid ASL signer
she says she doesn't know how to solve
the problem and she says in sign that
you add all okay so she's add and she
does that in gesture to see basically it
does lie as line underneath all four
numbers and they should just make up a
book okay okay so she is producing a
matching gesture she signs add all and
she gestures sweep bump above a book so
she has a matching gesture okay cool so
the proportion of problems on which
these deaf children gestured eighty
percent a lot of them who knows we went
back to the hearing kids to figure out
whether this is reasonable and it turns
out it's about the same but you know
here in just about 20 is seventy three
percent alright but now the crucial
question can we find mismatches low
weekend so here's an example of a
mismatch so what this kid does is she
says inside she does ad and she Punk's
it into the blank so add up to the equal
sign and put the answer in the blank but
while she's doing that she puts her
gesturing hand over the seven that equal
Adhan which is sort of a take away so
this is add and subtract
but that gesture it's not in sign it's
really a gesture so you don't
okay so let me deconstruct that here in
her signs she does add and then put so
it's add to the e cosine but in her
gesture she does add and then she covers
the seven which is really add subtract
okay so that's a mismatching you know
it's simultaneous very pretty okay great
so it turns out proportionally kids who
produce greater than three mismatches
42% in the deaf again a lot or a little
it's pretty comparable to what we found
in the hearing okay so in our great
position to ask the important question
so do i'm gonna ask this question here
i've what i've done is i've laid out the
kids as a function of how many
mismatches they produce prior to
instruction zero one two three whatever
okay
we have kids in each one of those bins
you can see how many and what we then
did i'm gonna show you is the proportion
of kids in each one of those bins who
profited who got better who succeeded on
the problems after instruction and by
succeeding they had to do five out of
six correct and they were all 0 to begin
with okay and we find it's a really
pretty picture so if you produce 0
mismatches prior to instruction you are
very unlikely to profit from that
instruction on the other hand if you
produce six mismatches you're very
likely to profit from instruction so
mismatch here is predicting learning for
the deaf kids just like it did for the
hearing kids and put in the same format
as i showed you earlier the deaf kid
data look pretty much identical okay so
what this suggests here is that gestures
to biess mismatch predicts learning just
as well as i sorry gesture sign mismatch
but explaining just as well as gesture
speech mismatch does which suggests this
isn't about juxtaposing hand and mouth
it's really about juxtaposing to
representational formats okay so i want
to add one more thing because i just we
put these data together recently like
and I started really putting them
together on the plane but it's a really
interesting point so I just want to get
it out there here what's interesting
about gesture is that or one of the
things is that it can be produced
simultaneously with speech is that
really important so in the previous work
that I showed you we had you know a
teacher producing gesture and speech at
the same time one strategy and gesture a
different strategy and speech
and we contrasted that with that same
teacher producing the same one strategy
in speech and another strategy in speech
of course it's sequential it has to be
sequential because you can't put speech
on top of each other okay but we could
spread gesture and speech out and that
would at least give us some leverage to
figure out whether what's important is
the gesture or the simultaneity
so we contrasted gesture with speech to
gesture then speech to speech then
speech so let me show you this is the
speech with gesture okay so you
basically saw that before that's what
we've used in the past all right here it
is with speech then gesture that sort of
sounds like it's gonna be weird but I
don't think it is actually
so she spreads it out it's really spread
out in some ways it's clearer because
it's not only gone together and then the
speech then speech you can imagine I
don't really need to show you that again
it she just does one and then the other
okay so well okay enough for you okay so
let me show you what happens we did
retention over time they got immediately
after training
one day after training because we wanted
to look at sleep actually and then four
weeks after training and we've
replicated the phenomenon that I showed
you before which is that when you get
speech with then speech it's worse than
when you get speech simultaneously with
gesture okay and it's sort of there's an
interesting pattern over time because
the speech then speech gets worse and
the speech with gesture actually gets a
little bit better so that's interesting
but now the crucial question is where
does you know speech then gesture go you
want to vote anybody want to vote it's
interesting it turns out it looks just
like speech than speech as a little
surprised at this I didn't think this is
my students predicted this I didn't
predict this I think it's really
interesting because it suggests that
something about gesture that one of the
important points about it is that it be
simultaneously produced with speech even
though it looks at some level harder to
process but there's something about it
that's really allowing integration or
perhaps even fostering integration of
the two ideas when they occur
simultaneously okay so these two
representational formats work best when
they occur simultaneously you just
briefly summarize so it I've tried to
convince you of is that the gestures we
produce provide a window onto our
thoughts they not only reflect what we
know but they can change what we know
and gesture is an act of the body which
I don't want to say is irrelevant here I
think it really might be important but
it may be the representational
possibilities that the body allows that
it can be simultaneously produce that it
can be uses imagistic stuff along with
speech okay and I want to just end with
a video somebody started with one all of
the gestures that I've been talking
about are gestures that co-occur with
speech they're gesture for speaking but
sometimes we gesture when we're just
thinking
and this is a really nice example of it
this is a kid who was taught how to use
the abacus he knows how to use the
advocates to add up numbers right um
what he's doing here abacus is taken
away and he's doing mental abacus so he
has been asked to add up ten two-digit
numbers in his head okay
without his abacus just using the abacus
in his mind and watch him and he's right
it's right almost every time too it's
really amazing you know he's doing these
movements we think he's doing the
movements that he did for the abacus and
the question they were trying to figure
out now is are these gestures for
thinking do they work in the same way as
gestures for speaking okay so let me
just end by thank you all my
collaborators my funders in thanking you
for listening
so I was wondering whether these sorts
of concepts also work when you're
listening to somebody as opposed to like
to forking yourself and this last thing
that I just showed you with a gesture
and speech is simultaneous that was
about the teacher did them and the kid
the learner was seeing it so that's not
what you mean okay so well we sort of
flip it it depends on who's listening it
is definitely the case that sometimes as
we listen we mimic the gestures of our
speaker and we did find that in one
study where the more when the teacher
gestured the child gestured to and the
kids who gestured were more likely to
learn than the kids who didn't gesture
but there it's totally confounded
because you don't know whether they
started gesturing because they were
ready to learn and they wanted to be
good gestures or you know whether
they're gesturing helped them you can't
tell so that's why we've moved to
manipulating it you know what I mean
yeah
which is probably good evening home team
places right right right right there
right I mean all this stuff and the
stuff that wake up is done on math I
think is really important because math
is such a statically displayed set of
ideas but no mathematician thinks that
those ideas are static and when they
talk about those ideas they gesture like
crazy and and Nunez and his colleagues
have really shown that all of those
movements are really important so for
teachers to convey those movements it's
probably essential for a novice to learn
them yeah I completely agree yep that's
an interesting question we've actually
shown that gesturing lightens your
cognitive load but why do you think
people can't just like whoo I mean if
you don't have arms of course you can't
gesture okay
but there's this wonderful example by
Rahman Ramachandran he talks about a
woman who with phantom limbs who feels
like she's gesturing
she says I'm gesturing well I'm talking
to you now and she actually it's a
lovely example because she says my arms
are moving was I'm when I'm talking but
she doesn't feel her arms and moving
when she's walking so she may it's not
like every movement is there so I don't
know I mean she had it she's phantom
limb she'd never moved her arms but I
you know if if people can't gesture I
don't want to argue that you can't learn
without moving your arms I think that
would that's not a good position for me
to be taking so but I would argue that
it facilitates that it really does
facilitate learning yeah
had a tower of Hanoi problem I told her
very heavy hands both imagine that then
I then you shift me to one-handed and
how'd you get the same effects right I
don't know I don't know I've never been
I've never had the guts to tell people
to imagine gesture in part because we
sort of don't really know what we're
doing when we gesture you know so so it
would be a little risky as a study but
really interesting so maybe you know
when I'm feeling risky I think it's a
good good yeah so if gestures can make
okay
yeah there I have a post out right now
who's really interested in that kind of
question she's looking at the face you
know kids you know gesture has always
been associated with emotion and with
affection with my stance and my attitude
and it's it hasn't been since David
McNeil and Adam Kendon that we started
to thinking about the ideas that were
conveyed so this is sort of a different
approach to gesture and we have ignored
all of these other things we really have
and I think it's time now to come back
and think about the emotion so hopefully
with this this postdoc we'll be able to
think about whether it play
I would think yes but I don't know I
really don't know it's a good question
yeah
there's a very hearty yes I don't think
of it as being the lexicon I mean we do
have lexical items in gesture we've got
you know thumbs up and this and all the
things that are emblems those really are
lexical items in the sense that I can do
this in you know what I mean
these smushy gestures nobody knows what
you're talking about unless they're
accompanied by speech so gesture is
really dependent upon speech for its
understanding and it's different from
language I mean no it doesn't fit into
any of the linguistic hierarchies or
rules because it's this imagistic stuff
I think that it also as it serve as
meaning at different levels of analysis
it's not at the lexical level it's more
at the propositional level so I think
it's a system that just works along with
speech or language sign as well but it's
not the same system so and it doesn't it
doesn't obey linguistic rules per se on
the other hand you know it can be it's
important for communication and thinking
it turns out though that those beliefs
that we have may not be totally correct
I haven't done those this work but Mary
and goober and Cornelia Mueller have
Europeans have both looked at Northern
Europe and southern Europe which is
really the divide there and what they
find actually is that everybody really
gestures and they gestured the same rate
but what's really different about the
Italians in particular the southern
Europeans and just a big you know
they're out there and they have more
emblems too they have these kinds of
things more of those but they're use
their whole bodies and so you know
they're not down here doing that sort of
stuff we don't know whether that matters
we have no idea but we know that the
rate of gesturing isn't that different
so it might matter you know if you're
used to listening looking at literal
gesture what I don't know what big
gesture does for you or if you're need
big gesture what little gesture does we
don't know anything about whether that's
important but at least we know that
across
cultures they really do gesture at the
same rate which i think is important for
the argument I'm making otherwise I'm
sort of in trouble yeah yeah I mean we
have done few studies with adults I've
looked at middle school kids and they
work the same and I've done adults
studying learning stereoisomers I don't
know why I chose everything it's it's
very majestic it's very special and we
found the same sort of effects where
gesture they they can produce mismatches
and the people who produce mismatches
are more likely to learn sterilized so I
don't think it's specific to children I
think it's about learning it's just a
lot easier to find to know what a kid
knows so we've gone with that but I do I
really might in my heart of hearts I
believe that it's really about learning
for adults or kids yeah um kind of in
the same vein as some cultures gesturing
more than others and also I'm talking
about empathy there has been studies
where people who can't mimic other
people's facial expressions as well are
less empathetic like people who get
Botox or something and I wondered but
are there people who are more kind of
like pick up on gestures more than
others and Emmas can learn better right
because we you know we tried to figure
out whether there are individual
differences in how well you pick up on
gestures we haven't found dramatic
differences in Hawaii but you know we
tried to actually see whether they're
good teachers and bad teachers and good
teachers pick up on gesture and bad
teachers don't
we've not we've not found great evidence
for that but that doesn't mean that it's
not there I think it's really an
interesting idea as to whether or not
you can pick up and read everybody can
read the information to some extent but
whether there are just subtleties that
you miss if you're not a good gesture
reader I don't know this field has
focused on individual differences not at
all it's interesting actually both in
terms of whether I'm a good gesture or a
bad gesture whether I'm good pick her up
or up gesture it just hasn't it's really
gone for a bigger phenomena
but I think it's ready it's ready to
engage some of these individual
differences questions and well you know
we'll see see yep it seems to me in part
a working memory issue yeah I think so
it seems so it seems like he's
kinesthetically
past so I would imagine that is kind of
like that when you're doing both
gesturing and verbal representations you
have a bigger bandwidth is that bit of
what you're finding with the speech is a
little it's a little tricky because I
mean even if he doesn't it they don't
have to move their hands when they do
this and they're still great at mental
abacus they're still great at mental
arithmetic so where our question is
whether there's a value-added to moving
your hands so we've been trying to sort
of you know force them to not move their
hands turns out if you just make them
not move their hands it doesn't affect
how their performance but if you make
them do some other motor things like tap
that really does affect their
performance so it does look like the
motor is playing some role we also what
we do is we put a a blind so they
couldn't see their hands to see whether
seeing their hands matter that doesn't
matter it's got to be it's feeling but
we have to play around with it more to
see what's going on yeah
but you said before about gesture cannot
be in terrible on its home it's really
an issue of alignment and so the degree
to which the signer can interpret the
gesture as aligned with their indicates
during the experimental context is
completely out of line so whether it's
three about about Simonet or its ability
to reconstruct an alignment between the
gesture and that it's really good to
push me on what I mean by simultaneity
because it's some level of a signer you
know he did that she did this and then
this and her gesture was produced at the
same time you know you got two hands you
can gesture with one you can sign with
another but there is a little bit more
sequentiality to it but it's all on the
same problem sort of you know it's hard
to say where the gesture isn't with but
I think that's a really important point
like I really haven't thought through
these simultaneity results since we
really just got them but I do think
about this more because for sign it's
got to be a little bit more off although
there is some other evidence that you
can so if I if I I can lay gesture on
top of my hand no so if I if if in my
gesture I indicate the width of
something you know I can take my sign
and expand it or not and all and that
can be done simultaneously so it's not
the addition ones particularly no
although you know they they definitely
intermingled it because she did gesture
then sign and then gesture again right
it's not such yes right Thanks
right right right right yeah no
absolutely I really have to think about
what I mean by simultaneity yeah that's
a really good point
okay